[Musique]
avec vous on fera ce matin bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse internationale de ce mardi hélène
on en parlait à l'instant avec damien
l'intensification de l'offensive russe
dans le don bassa à l'est du pays nous
pouvons maintenant affirmer que les
troupes russes ont commencé la bataille
pour le dombass a annoncé hier volodymyr
zelensky une déclaration le voit à la
une du journal britannique guardian qui
rappelle la volonté de vladimir poutine
de s'emparer totalement du poumon
économique de l'ukraine cette escalade
militaire majeure augmente les peurs
concernant lé civile dit un autre
quotidien britannique évoque notamment
la crainte que la principale route
d'évacuation des réfugiés se retrouve
coupée à cause des bombardements sur le
vivent à l'ouest du pays cette fois
cette nouvelle phase des combats sera
sans doute différente de la campagne
ratée pour prendre kiev mais ce qui ne
changera probablement pas c'est la
brutalité avec laquelle les soldats
russes se comporte envers les civils
ukrainien prévient de washington post
alarmé par la tactique hybride employés
par les forces russes une stratégie
combinant le bombardement aveugle des
zones urbaines et la cruauté je cite
envers les civils parmi ces actes de
cruauté il ya les violences sexuelles
contre les femmes près de deux mois
après le début de la guerre les
témoignages de victimes se multiplient
et les nations unies appelle maintenant
le lancement d'une enquête indépendante
selon libération qui souligne que
l'ampleur de ses crimes de ces violences
sexuelles est difficile à estimer dans
un conflit toujours actif sans compter
que la plupart des victimes traumatisées
ne sont pas encore en mesure de parler
j'avais peur des conséquences au kazoo
les reviendrai j'ai donc signé un papier
comme quoi je n'avais pas été violée
raconte d'ailleurs l'une de ses victimes
dans le temps le quotidien suisse
confirme la multiplication de ces
témoignages de femmes violées mais
rapporte que les experts estiment qu'il
est encore trop tôt pour considérer le
viol comme une arme de guerre de l'armée
russe en russie et là nous il faut le
rappeler une grande partie de la
population n'a pas accès aux témoignages
de ces exactions dont vous venez de
parler la popularité de vladimir poutine
semble renforcée par le conflit
interrogé par la croix une jeune
moscovite témoigne de ce que deux
colonels les indécis seraient devenus
des partisans de l'opération militaire
comme on l'appelle en russie non pas
qu'il veuille d'une guerre mais pour les
sanctions prouve que les occidentaux
attendent est une occasion pour punir la
russie du coup beaucoup se sont
radicalisées dans leur soutien au
kremlin constate-t-elle plat d'ymir
poutine hélène qui se mobilisent pour
soutenir une église à jérusalem qui
s'appelle l'église 9 qui équipera ce
israël de ne pas soutenir l'ukraine
d'après le figaro le président russe a
adressé une lettre au premier ministre
israélien naftali bennet réclamant ce
complexe religieux promis il ya trois
ans par son prédécesseur benyamin
netanyahu à l'occasion d'un échange pour
la libération d'une jeune israélienne
accusée en russie de trafic de drogue un
échange non validés par la cour suprême
israélienne et que vladimir poutine a
donc rappelé au bon souvenir de l'état
hébreu après que celui ci a voté pour
l'exclusion de la russie de la
commission des droits de l'homme de
l'onu à cause évidemment de la guerre en
ukraine le délicat exercice d'équilibré
d'israël partagé entre son désir de
plaire à ses alliés occidentaux et sa
volonté de contrôler la syrie son
puissant voisin influencé par la russie
ne suffit toujours pas à moscou critique
le quotidien israélien jerusalem
voilà le président russe qui réclame
donc cette église à jérusalem pardon
pour le savonnage la russie de vladimir
poutine hélène envers laquelle marine le
pen ici en france a longtemps été
accusée de complaisance dans une longue
tribune publiée par le figaro la
candidate du à rennes à la
présidentielle exposé ce qu'est la
france qu'elle aime et qu'elle veut
défendre un texte dans lequel elle
promet entre autres que les milliers de
quartier en récession feront l'objet
d'une reconquête républicaine
systématique et qu'un strict contrôle
des flux migratoires sera organisée pour
faire face à la pression migratoire je
la cite à dire dans le figaro marine le
pen emmanuel macron dont les programmes
sont passés au crible par la presse
étrangère selon le financial times cette
présidentielle aurait entériné la
disparition du traditionnel clivage
français entre la droite et la gauche
efface et donc ce clivage remplacé par
un affrontement entre les patriots
incarné par le pen et les globalistes
avec emmanuel macron pour le quotidien
espagnol el país une éventuelle arrivée
de la candidate du fn à l'elysée
poserait un risque existentiel pour
l'europe puisque pour la première fois
depuis 75 ans l'un des membres de l' axe
franco-allemand passerait de la tête du
projet européen à une guerre d'usure
contre lui une victoire de marine le pen
serait catastrophique pour le et
mettrait même en danger son existence
estime aussi le journal saoudien arab
news qui attribue l'ascension du rn
virage progressif de la droite
d'emmanuel macron notamment sur l'islam
une évolution qui aurait indirectement
aider marine le pen en normalisant je
cite le racisme marine le pen gagne ce
sera la faute d' emmanuel macron est
écrite en une on se quitte là dessus
elle donc depuis deux jours pauline la
presse anglo saxonne semble
littéralement fasciné par un cliché
d'emmanuel macron photographié samedi
dernier dans les coulisses d'un meeting
chemise ouverte sur un torse velu ce
détail figurez vous a nourri une
avalanche d'articles de daily telegraph
relève ce matin que tous les dirigeants
mondiaux ma foi ont leurs petites bottes
secrètes quand ils cherchent
désespérément à gagner des votes joe
biden ses lunettes d'aviateur donald
trump sa casquette rouge et emmanuel
macron donc ses poils une forêt de
virilité que le quotidien compare à
celle d'austin powers l'espion délurée
ou encore à celle de barry gibb le
chanteur des bee gees
déployer un tel trésor de guerre pour
séduire les électeurs est ce une
stratégie accepta le s'interroge
doctement le quotidien britannique qui
conclut que et bien sûr ce point du mois
marine le pen n'a évidemment aucune
chance
merci beaucoup hélène on vous retrouve